hello Google cloud load-balancing
enables you to scale your applications
from zero to full throttle with no
pre-warming needed you can distribute
your load balance compute resources in a
single or multiple regions close to your
users and meet your high availability
requirements cloud load balancing puts
your resources behind a single anycast
IP and allows you to scale your
resources up and down with intelligent
auto scaling cloud load balancing can
support HTTP HTTPS tcp and UDP we are
excited to introduce a new load
balancing UI that enables you to
configure any of these flavors of load
balancing intuitively and easily through
a single interface with the new UI you
simply pick the protocol configure the
related parameters and you're done in
order to create a new HTTP load balancer
click create load balancer now click
start configuration in the HTTP HTTPS
load balancing section
fill in the name of your load balancer
you can use lowercase letters numbers
and hyphens click back-end configuration
to configure where your incoming traffic
will be redirected from the drop-down
menu you can select an existing back-end
service or you can create a new back-end
service now enter the name for your
back-end service from the backend
section select an instance group
finally select a health check from the
drop-down at the bottom
your backends are now configured the
next step is to determine how your
traffic will be directed click host and
path rules from the left panel the first
row determines where any traffic not
explicitly with a host and path rule
will be sent click add host and path
rule to add a second row now fill it in
the third step is configuring your
front-end click front-end configuration
to configure the protocol IP address
port and certificate if necessary once
that is done you can click review and
finalize to review your configuration
finally click the Create button to
create your load balancer when the new
load balancer is created you can click
its row to expand it and see its details
if you want to modify its configuration
click the edit button you can go through
the same steps you went through during
load balancer creation backend
configuration host and path rules and
front-end configuration finally click
the Update button if you want to apply
your changes or click cancel to discard
your changes in order to create a new
TCP load balancer click create load
balancer now click the start
configuration button in the tcp load
balancing section
fill in the name of your load balancer
you can use lowercase letters numbers
and hyphens
now click back-end configuration to
configure where your incoming traffic
will be redirected select the region
where your instance group is located
select an instance group you want to use
select a health check from the drop down
menu click front-end configuration to
configure the IP address import click
Add front-end IP import and enter a port
number
now you can click review and finalize to
review a configuration
finally click the create button to
create your tcp load bouncer
when the new load bouncer is created you
can click it's row to expand it and see
its details you can use the edit button
to modify the configuration you can
similarly configure a UDP load balancer
as well to view all your load balancers
go to networking
and click on load balancing
once you have configured your load
bouncers you can view them and also view
their details as well we invite you to
give the new load balancing UIs bin and
cloud Google com